6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish, I'm Sam
And I'm Neil
Come on Neil, let's make a start
I've got a deadline to meet today and I haven't finished my work yet
Let me guess, it's because you delayed and delayed
And put your work off until the last minute as usual
You're a real procrastinator, Sam, someone who keeps delaying things that need to be done
What can I say? I work better when a deadline is approaching
I see, but did you know that people who procrastinate have higher levels of stress and lower well-being?
Procrastination is also linked with lower financial and career success
So there's a lot of reasons not to do it
In this programme we're discussing procrastination
The act of delaying things that must be done until later
Often because they're difficult, boring or unpleasant
And as usual we'll be learning some new vocabulary along the way
So without wasting any more time I have a question for you, Sam
The fact that procrastinating or putting things off is bad for us
Doesn't stop people doing it
According to recent research by DePaul University in Chicago
What percentage of people procrastinate so much that it interferes with their day-to-day life?
Is it a 10% b 20% or c 30%
I'll guess that around 10% of people have a serious procrastination problem
Okay, Sam, we'll find out the answer later in the programme
Sam is certainly not alone in putting things off until the last minute
Here's Ella Al-Shamahi, presenter of BBC Radio 4's Why Do We Do That?
Talking to comedian Ishaan Akbar about his procrastination habit
Would you say Ishaan that you're a procrastinator?
I am a serial procrastinator without a shadow of a doubt
Why? Why do you think you procrastinate?
Over the years I've told myself that I procrastinate because I work better under pressure
That's what I've told myself
Ishaan thinks that he is a procrastinator without a shadow of a doubt
A phrase which is used to emphasise that you are completely certain of something
Ishaan also says that like Sam, he works better under pressure
when he feels stressed or anxious because of having too much to do
But maybe also like Sam, Ishaan has a problem organising his workload and managing his time
Hang on Neil, my time management skills are okay
Thank you, with me it's more of an emotional response
I see a mountain of work feel threatened and think how on earth will I finish all that?
What Sam says is supported by a theory of human evolution
which explains how putting things off is an emotional response
Back when we were living in caves life was dangerous and short
and our ancestors were impulsive
They acted suddenly on instinct without thinking about the consequences of what they were doing
Back then being impulsive was a good thing
But in modern life with work goals and deadlines
when we are impulsive and get distracted we procrastinate
So rather than being a problem with time management
Sam should blame her caveman ancestors who acted on impulse
Let's listen again to comedian Ishaan Akbar talking about how he feels when he procrastinates
A lot of stuff you read about procrastination focuses on the time management element of it
I've probably got a better sense that for me it seems very squarely around the emotional aspect of it
Perhaps I get more emotional gratification from doing it last minute
I need to understand why I prefer that over the calm serenity of getting things done with oodles of time in my hands
In the same way that our ancestors felt good living on impulse
Ishaan thinks he gets gratification of feeling of pleasure and satisfaction from doing things at the last minute
What he doesn't understand is why he prefers to work under pressure
Instead of finishing calmly with oodles or lots of time
Unlike Ishaan I'd rather finish my work feeling relaxed but there never seems to be enough time
Well breaking down the task into smaller stages also breaks down the level of threat you feel from your workload
Also forgiving yourself for procrastinating in the past seems helpful in avoiding procrastinating in the future
So forgive yourself and start making changes Sam before you end up like the time-wasters in my question
What percentage of people procrastinate so much that it interferes with day-to-day life?
Well I guessed it was 10%
Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid in fact around 20% of us have a procrastination habit
So strong it makes life difficult
Okay let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this program on procrastination
Delaying or putting off doing things until later, often because they're difficult, unpleasant or boring
The phrase without a shadow of a doubt is used to emphasise that you are completely certain of something
If you're under pressure you feel stressed or anxious because of having too much to do
Impulsive behaviour is sudden and spontaneous, done without thinking about the consequences
Gradification means a feeling of pleasure and satisfaction
And finally when you have oodles of something you have a very large amount of something pleasant
Like time which once again we've run out of
I'm rushing off to finish my work Neil but remember to make time to join us again soon here at 6 Minute English
Bye for now
Goodbye
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com